we got a break yesterday from manic
sentence fragments and verbal glitches
and we actually heard for about 45 solid
minutes from former president barack
obama at a rally for joe biden in
philadelphia
and um it was refreshing only in so far
as it was normal english it was normal
adult communication now you might say
rally i hope that was safe it was very
safe
it was a drive-in rally people sat in
their cars and
truly you know this is not obama
deification
this is just recognizing that we've been
lacking even the most basic ability for
our president
to express himself and to think clearly
for a very long time and my audience who
joined me
live for this event by the way far
larger audience for this obama event
than we've been seeing for the trump
events that we've been covering live
the audience seemed to realize that you
know you don't have to agree with
everything barack obama did you don't
have to agree with barack obama on uh
the way he negotiated obamacare or drone
policy or many other things
the rec the the recognition seemed to be
yesterday
that we as a country are desperate
in desperate need of some normality
some normalization of relationships with
our allies
returning to sanity to some degree and
barack obama not only reminding us of
that but brutally
going after donald trump during this
rally trump was
triggered by it he started tweeting
about barack obama
almost immediately trump on his way to
his own rally at the time
tweeting a bizarre breitbart conspiracy
article
about barack obama as barack obama was
speaking
and we know that donald trump is very
jealous of barack obama
envious that barack obama can speak
coherently and he should be
and i understand why let's look at a few
clips barack obama
here making direct reference in fact to
trump's retweeting of conspiracy
theories
as this speech was going on barack obama
actually uh rather donald trump
retweeted a conspiracy article about
barack obama here is obama
commenting on the conspiracies and with
joe and kamala
at the helm you're not going to have to
think about
the crazy things they said every day
and that's worth a lot you're not going
to have to argue about them
every day
[Music]
it just won't be so exhausting you you
might be able to have a thanksgiving
dinner without having an argument
be able to go about your lives knowing
that the president
is not going to retweet conspiracy
theories
[Music]
about secret cabals running the world or
or
that navy seals didn't actually kill bin
laden
think about that the president the
united states retweeted that
imagine what
what and then continuing on to point out
the cartoonish absurdity
of donald trump promising to protect
pre-existing conditions
while trying to get rid of obamacare
which protects pre-existing conditions
you know republicans love to say
right before an election that they'll
protect your pre-existing conditions
now joe and i actually protected your
policies to make sure people with
pre-existing conditions could get health
insurance and have coverage
we did it through something called the
affordable care act
aka obamacare
and republicans try
to repeal or undermine it more than 60
times
and when they've been asked about they
they keep on promising we're going to
have a great replacement
they said it's coming it's been coming
in two weeks for the last 10 years
where is it where is this great plan to
replace obamacare
they've had 10 years to do it there is
no plan
they've never had one well said there uh
then barack obama
weighing in on the undisclosed chinese
bank account of donald trump
and pointing out exactly as i did
imagine
if it had been obama or hillary with
undisclosed
chinese bank accounts we know that he
continues to do business with china
because he's got a secret chinese bank
account
how is that possible how is that
possible
a secret chinese bank account listen can
you imagine if i had a secret chinese
bank account
when i was running for reelection
you think you think my you think fox
news might have been a little concerned
about that
they would have called me beijing berry
as i've pointed out before it's actually
worse than this
if barack obama had done any of the
hundreds of scandalous things that
donald trump has done
it would have been a multi-month story
with demands for congressional
investigations which if republicans
controlled the house and senate at the
time
they would have gotten congressional
investigations about a hypothetical
beijing berry
chinese bank account in this next clip
you can actually
hear the exasperation in barack obama's
voice pointing out that donald trump is
running medicaid right now
and trying to kick people off of it and
many other backwards things are going on
and our water is right now run by an
energy lobbyist
that gives polluters free reign to dump
unlimited poison
into our air and water the labor
department that's supposed to protect
workers
and their rights right now it's run by a
corporate lobbyist
who's declared war on workers guts
protections
to to keep essential folks safe during a
pandemic
makes it easier for big corporations to
shortchange them on their wages
the interior department that's supposed
to protect our public lands
and wild spaces our wildlife
and our wilderness and right now that's
run by an
oil lobbyist who's determined to sell
them to the highest bidder
you've got the education department
that's supposed to give every
kid a chance and that's run by a
billionaire who guts rules designed to
protect
students from getting ripped off by
for-profit colleges
and stiff-arm students looking for loan
relief in the middle of an economic
collapse
i mean the person who runs medicaid
right now
is doing their best to kick people off
of medicaid
barack obama very very astutely pointing
out here
much like bernie sanders has pointed out
much like noam chomsky has pointed out
we make
incremental change for the better and
then we make another incremental change
and then another and the fact that we
don't get a hundred percent of what we
want right away is not a good reason
not to vote it means we've got a vote
and then get some change and then vote
some more
and then get some more change and then
keep on voting
until we get it right
this is very well said this is a point
i've been making for a while now i know
that there are people who will hear that
and they will say that's neoliberal
status quo trash and to them i would say
as i've said before
give me the receipts show me the
evidence
that the accelerationist ideas actually
achieve better results than what barack
obama
is talking about here i care about
reality not about ideology
and i have not found such facts so
overall
very well done i think this could
actually pay dividends tonight during
the second and final presidential debate
i expect trump will be extra furious and
likely to self-destruct as a result of
barack obama now getting involved
it's not about barack obama being
perfect it's not about barack obama
being the progressive dream it's just
a desire to return to more normal times
when our elected officials understood
and accepted science
when our elected officials maintained
normal relationships with other
countries and weren't a global
laughingstock
barack obama will be uh rallying for joe
biden on saturday in florida
very important and i do actually think
that whatever your thought is about
barack obama in analyzing the election
from an
objective standpoint i think this very
much helps joe biden remember
that uh george w bush was not out there
campaigning for john mccain uh was not
was not well liked enough to be able to
do it george w bush was certainly not
out there
campaigning for donald trump in 2016
and the fact that uh it is so obvious
that this is an advantage to joe biden
tells us a lot about the importance of
job of barack obama being out there
doing it
we'll have more of this and clips on our
instagram
page david pakman show on instagram
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video